NARRATOR: The following content
is provided under a
Creative Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational
resources for free.
To make a donation or to view
additional materials from
hundreds of MIT courses, visit
MIT OpenCourseWare at
ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: Today, I want to
spend a fair amount of time,
to start out with, talking about
this business of, how do
you go from pass band to a
baseband in a wireless system
and some of these questions
about time reference and all
of these things.
When we were dealing with
ordinary channels that didn't
have fading in them and didn't
have motion or anything like
that, it was a fairly
straightforward thing to think
of a transmitter having its
time reference and the
receiver locking in on its time
reference, which had a
certain amount of delay
from what the
transmitter was doing.
As soon as you start having
multiple paths, each with
different delays in them, this
starts to get confusing.
If you try to write
it down carefully,
it gets doubly confusing.
If these path lanes are changing
dynamically, it gets
even more confusing.
So I wanted to spend a little
bit of time at the beginning
of the hour trying
to sort that out.
It's not sorted out that
well in the notes.
As you'll see, it doesn't get
sorted out too well here
either because the problem is,
whenever you write everything
down, it becomes a nightmare.
So this is just another effort
at trying to do this.
Let's start out by just looking
at a single path.
This single path, we're going to
assume, has a time varying
attenuation, which we'll call
beta of t and a time varying
delay, which we'll
call tau of t.
Namely, this is the same thing
that we did before.
We started out with a fixed
transmitter and a fixed receiver.
Now, since we're allowing both
the attenuation and the delay
to vary, but only
having one path.
What we're essentially thinking
is, that is the
receiver, which is in a vehicle
for example, which is
moving away from or towards
the transmitter.
So these are the, or in a sense
an easy way of keeping
track of that physical
situation.
So the response at passband to
a real waveform, x of t, it's
going to be just beta sub t
times x of t minus tau of t.
In other words, here's
the delay here.
Here's the attenuation
here and we just
have a single path.
Now if you start out with a
baseband waveform, if you
start out with a complex
baseband waveform, say u of t,
you're going to shift this up
first to a positive frequency
band, which we'll call u sub p
of t, which is u of t e to the
2 pi ifct and you're going to
transmit it as x of t, which
is equal to two times
a real part of that.
Half the time we've been dealing
with going through
this modulation from baseband
to passband in terms of
cosines and sines.
Half the time we've been doing
it in terms of complex
exponentials.
One of the problems that appears
as soon as you get
into wireless is that if you
really like to do things in
terms of cosines and sines, you
really run into a lot of
trouble here because with phases
varying all over the
place, it just becomes very,
very difficult to track what's
going on with all of the cosine
terms and all of the
sine terms.
So what we sort of have to wind
up with here is this, in
a sense, simpler but more
abstract viewpoint where we
think of modulation as being a
two step process, where we
first take the take the low pass
waveform, move it up in
frequency and then we add on the
negative frequency part as
an afterthought and then at the
receiver, what we're going
to do is have a Hilbert filter,
which you would never
build, of course.
You would always build it in
terms of cosines and sines,
but conceptually have a Hilbert
filter which blocks
off that negative frequency part
and then you just shift
things down in frequency
again.
So that's the way we're thinking
about this here, so
we're going to have u of
t shifted up and then
transmitted as 2 times the
real part of up of t and
therefore, it's going
to get received --
the received waveform
at the passband.
We're still using the timing
at the transmitter.
That's the purpose of going
through all this analysis, to
look at what's going on at
transmit time and what's going
on at receive time.
So in terms of transmit time,
this received waveform at
passband is just the attenuation
term times x of t
minus tau of t, which is two
times the real part of theta
of t times this positive
frequency part.
Now when you write it out in all
of its glory, it's 2 times
the real part of the attenuation
times the input
you started with, but now this
has been delayed by tau of t
and e to the 2 pi ifct, but this
was the carrier that was
put on at the transmitter,
physically at the transmitter
and now we're at the receiver,
so that carrier has gotten
delayed by a factor
of tau sub t.
The question is, how do
you demodulate this?
How do you come down again from
transmitter to receiver?
What we've thought all along and
what makes a lot of sense
until you start putting these
delays in, which are really a
pain in the neck, is that what
we're going to do is just
multiply this positive frequency
waveform by e to the
minus 2 pi i f sub ct, but
that's not what we're going to
do because the receiver sitting
there and the receiver
has to recover timing
and it has to
recover carrier frequency.
So what's it going to do?
It's going to figure out what
the timing is and the timing
that it wants is at time 0, it
wants to be seeing what the
transmitter transmitted
at transmit time 0.
In other words, if you look at
what the transmitter was doing
at time 0, it was sending, say,
the first bit that was
going to be sent.
In receiving this, we want to
have our timing so we're
looking at that first
bit sent.
So our timing is going to be
shifted from what it was then.
So we're going to take
this new timing.
The receiver clock time is now
going to be t prime, which is
t minus this delay term.
If you get confused between
the minuses and the pluses
here, don't worry about it.
I get confused about them too
and the only way I can
straighten them out as to put
down one or the other and then
spend ten minutes looking at
it and try to figure out --
after I write it down --
whether it should really be a
plus or a minus and I think
these sines are right, but I'm
not going to try to argue why
in realtime.
But anyway, this received
waveform now, as a function of
received time, is going to be
the received waveform and in
terms of transmit time --
and in place of t now, I'm going
to have t prime so that
since you t prime is equal to t
minus tau of t, this is why
it's t prime plus tau of t.
In other words, what I'm looking
at now, at time 0 at
the receiver is what was
being transmitted a
little while ago.
So that's this term and that's
going to be the real part of
this, where I've taken account
of all of these shift terms.
Now if you look at this
carefully, you see that u of t
minus t of t is turned
into tau of t prime.
This term has turned into 2 pi
ifct prime, so everything is
fine there.
What I should have done with
this term is to compensate for
the fact that I'm now looking at
it in a different time and
at this point, what I'm going to
do is to say, this quantity
is changing so slowly
with time that I
don't care about that.
If you really try to adjust this
to make it right, it's a
terrible mess.
So we're just not going
to worry about it.
So what we receive then is
approximately equal to this
where the approximation is due
to the fact that I'm not
evaluating this attentuation
term at exactly the right
time, because it's a pain
in the neck to do so.
All of this stuff with wireless,
you simply have to
make approximations all
over the place.
You have to make crazy modeling
assumptions all over
the place, because the
physical medium is so
complicated that you can't do
much else and the whole
question is trying to make the
right approximations and get
some sense of which thing's very
fast and which thing's
very slowly.
So that's the equation
that we had.
What we receive now at passband,
but at the received
time scale is this
quantity here.
So what's the receiver
going to do?
The receiver, at its time is
going to demodulate by
multiplying by e to the
minus 2 pi ifct prime.
First, we're going to take away
this 2 times the real
sine by going through the
Hilbert filter, which just
removes this.
At that point, we have a complex
positive frequency
waveform and then we're going
to multiply that positive
frequency waveform by e to the
minus 2 pi ifct prime, where t
prime is the only thing the
receiver knows anything about.
So after you shift the baseband
with a recovered
carrier in receiver time, what
you get in receiver time is v
of t prime as equal to beta
of t prime; namely, the
attenuation at t prime -- or
this is the approximate part
of it -- times what
was actually set.
So now, think of this as saying,
suppose this delay
term is actually changing
with time.
Namely, it's some tau 0 minus a
velocity term, vt divided by
the velocity of light.
In other words, the time delay
that you incur, where the
change in the time delay that
you incur, is due to the time
that it takes light to travel
from where the receiver was to
where the receiver is now.
We can also write that as tau
0 minus the Doppler shift
times the time divided by
the carrier frequency.
Now here's another
approximation, because what
we're sending --
I mean, this quantity
here is exact.
When you try to convert from
the velocity, which you're
going to, for what it does in
frequency, which is the
Doppler shift, it's a function
of the frequency.
Here what we're assuming is that
all the frequencies we're
dealing with are so close to the
carrier frequency that we
can just ignore everything
else.
So we're just writing this as
the Doppler shift divided by
this carrier frequency.
Now if you view the passband
waveform, going into a
baseband of modulation and you
think of doing this in
transmit time, what are
you going to do?
In terms of transmit time,
you've got to get rid of not
this term, but this
thing here.
So in terms of transmit time,
you're going to be multiplying
by e to the minus 2 pi i times
carrier frequency minus the
Doppler shift.
So the thing that's happening
is that time at the
transmitter gets spread out a
little bit at the receiver.
In other words, as this
receiving antenna is moving
away from the transmitter, a
period of time like this at
the transmitter is a period of
time like this at the receiver
and therefore, a certain number
of cycles of carrier at
the transmitter looks like a
different number of cycles of
carrier at the receiver.
Therefore, if you're dealing
with transmit time, you're
taking account of this
Doppler shift.
You're multiplying not by the
carrier frequency, but by the
carrier frequency minus
the Doppler shift.
If you do it in receiver time,
you're just multiplying by the
by this carrier frequency,
because the trouble is, your
clock is running
a little slow.
Because your clock is running
a little slow, you think
you're demodulating at the
actual carrier frequency,
whereas in terms of what the
transmitter thinks, you're
doing something else.
If you all got confused when you
studied relativity, this
is exactly the same problem you
got confused about there.
There's nothing very mysterious
about it or hard
about it, except that to most
of us, time is a very
fundamental quantity
and you don't like
to monkey with that.
If you can't count on time being
what it's supposed to
be, you're really
in deep trouble.
When you try to write equations
that do that, it
makes things very,
very tough also.
So anyway, the result after we
look at this in both ways, is
that you get the same answer
each way, but the receiver
sees the carrier frequency and
sees this carrier frequency in
transmitter time and
it sees this
frequency in received time.
Of course, the receiver only
sees received time because the
receiver sitting there trying
to measure from the waveform
coming in what that carrier
frequency is and what that
time base is.
So now it gets to be fun.
We look at multiple paths.
When you look at it in transmit
time, what gets
received at the receiver,
according to the
transmit clock --
so here we are at the
transmitter and we're peering
at what's going on at this
distant receiver and you now
have the thing that we've talked
about in the notes
where you have all these
different paths.
Each path is associated with a
certain attenuation and each
path is associated with
a time delay.
This can be written in terms of
what has gotten modulated
up from baseband as 2 times the
real part of this sum --
of beta j of t times the
positive frequency part of
what got transmitted and then
it now has this delay in it.
This can be rewritten in the
same way that we did before,
but now we just have all of
these paths in there instead
of one path.
If you look at this expression
then, we have all of these
propogation delay terms.
We have this baseband input,
which has been delayed in
different ways for each path
and you have have this
exponential, which has
been delayed also.
So at this point, the receiver
is in a real pickle because if
the receiver is smart enough
to see -- yes?
AUDIENCE:
[UNINTELLIGIBLE PHRASE]
PROFESSOR: The receiver
doesn't know anything.
It's like you're driving in your
car, you're talking on
your cell phone and
your cell phone --
I mean, the only way your cell
phone knows that you're moving
is that the cell phone is
getting some waveform coming
in and it has to tell from that
waveform what's going on.
So it's going to do things like
the carrier tracking that
we were talking about before and
it's not going to have too
much trouble because all of
these changes are taking place
relatively slowly, relative
to this very high --
either one gigabits or two
gigabits or four gigabits, or
what have you, carrier
frequency.
So all these changes look like
almost nothing, but at the
same time, they're fairly
important because they keep
changing faces.
But anyway, in terms of the
transmitter clock, this is
what you actually receive.
So at this point, what the
receiver has to do is it has
to retrieve clock time and the
clock time that it retrieves
is going to be --
receiver clock time is --
is t minus tau 0 sub t --
so it's t prime equals
t minus tau 0 sub t.
That's the same thing it was
before, except that this tau
zero of t here doesn't
really amount to
anything physical anymore.
It's just whatever the circuitry
that we have trying
to recover carrier and trying
to recover timing --
it's just whatever that happens
to come up with, so
with this best sense of the
timing it should use if it's
going to try to detect
what the signal is.
So it's some arbitrary
value and again, this
is varying in time.
So again what we have is now
this expression becomes really
messy, because instead of
having a receiver time
variation, which cancels out
what the actual variation in
path length is, you really
have two terms that are
different and you have the same
thing in terms of this
phase, which is changing
and this is the
more important term.
But anyway, you have that.
You can then demodulate.
What do you do when
you demodulate?
You take this thing in receiver
time and you multiply
by e to the 2 pi i, e to
the minus 2 pi i --
this carrier frequency, what
you think it is, times this
time reference, what you
think that is --
So that term has disappeared and
what we then wind up with
is the carrier frequency times
these two terms here.
That's to the left there.
These two terms turn out to have
both Doppler shift terms
in them and also time
spread terms.
So when we write that out in
terms of Doppler shift, what
we wind up with is the input,
which is then delayed by some
arbitrary amount of time,
where this is our best
estimate of the right time to
use and this is the actual
time on that path.
The thing that's happening here,
which you don't see in
the notes unfortunately, in
the notes, it pretty much
looks at things as far as
transmit time is concerned.
Therefore, what you see is
expressions for impulse
response where the impulse
response is at some time much
later than time 0.
You have a --
I mean, you put in an impulse
of time 0, what you see is
stuff dribbling out over some
very tiny interval, but a good
deal later than what
got put in.
What we want to do now is to
shift that so that in fact,
when we look at filtering and
things like that, we have a
filter which starts a little bit
before 0 and ends a little
bit after 0 and that's the
whole purpose of this.
If you don't think my purposes
just to confuse you, it really
isn't, although I realize this
is very confusing, but you
sort of have to go through with
it to see why these time
shifts appear in the places
where they do.
But anyway, up here in the
phase, you wind up with the
Doppler shift terms and down
here, when you're worrying
about the input waveform, you're
worrying about these
time shift terms.
We'll see we'll see how they
come in a little later.
To make the expression a little
bit easier, let me look
at tau j prime of t as tau j
minus tau 0 and let me look at
the Doppler differential as
the Doppler that actually
occurs on path j minus what
the receiver thinks the
Doppler is.
This is this receiver term that
we've demodulated by and
therefore, we've really gotten
rid of this term.
Then when we rewrite this
received baseband waveform --
and I've now gotten rid of the
t primes because everything
we've done up until now, we've
just automatically assumed
that the receiver timing and the
transmit timing, we didn't
have to be careful about it and
it wasn't until we got to
wireless that we do have
to be careful about it.
So now we're throwing it out
again and what we have is
these attenuations, which
are very slowly varied.
These terms, which are now
delayed by this difference
between the actual delay and
what the receiver is assuming
that the light ought to be.
So these are really just
differential delays relative
to each other.
These are Doppler shifts
relative to each other.
So that's the whole receive
baseband waveform then.
If you look at this, it's not
apparent where the carrier
frequency is coming in and the
carrier frequency is coming in
because these Doppler shifts
have the carrier
frequency in them.
Namely, the Doppler shift is the
velocity times the carrier
frequency divided by
the speed of light.
One of the things you have to
be very careful with in the
wireless business, is that
everybody thinks it's a neat
idea to be able to be able to
go up to higher and higher
frequencies.
When you go from one gigahertz
up to four gigahertz, one of
the things that you have to
deal with is that every
Doppler shift you're dealing
with is now four times higher
than it was before.
So there's one big disadvantage
in operating at
extremely high frequencies.
It's not necessarily a bad
thing, but it's there and if
you have a bunch of different
paths which are all acting in
different ways, you
suddenly wind up
with some real problems.
The received baseband waveform
on path j is going to change
completely over an interval --
1 over 4 times the
magnitude of this
differential Doppler shift.
The Doppler shift might be
positive or negative, but if
you look at this expression up
here, that's the amount of
time that it takes for
this quantity to
change by pi over 2.
When this changes by pi over 2,
this exponential goes from
its maximum one down to zero or
it goes from zero to minus
one or it goes from minus one
to zero or from zero up to
plus one, and that's a
pretty major change.
So the interval which is
required to do that is 1 over
4 times that Doppler shift.
The Doppler spread now is
defined as the difference
between the maximum Doppler
shift and the
minimum Doppler shift.
If we choose this Doppler shift
D sub 0 that we had,
because of what the receiver
was doing, seeing all these
different Doppler shifts and
trying to come up with
something in the middle, that's
pretty close to what
the receiver thinks it should
be using as far as receive
time is concerned.
So it's the maximum plus the
minimum divided by 2 and then
each of these differential
Doppler shifts is going to be
somewhere between that overall
Doppler spread minus Doppler
spread over 2 and plus Doppler
spread over 2.
It goes from --
minus D over 2 up to plus D over
2 and this difference in
here, is strangely enough, D.
So what we've done is by
adjusting our received
timing --
and slowing it down or speeding
it up if necessary,
is we wind up with Doppler
shifts that are sort of spread
around from negative Doppler
shifts to plus Doppler shifts.
What that means is, if you look
at this expression, it
takes a period of
time, about --
here we had 1 over 4 times the
differential Doppler, which is
now 1 over 2 times this overall
Doppler spread.
So what that says is, there's
a coherence time on the
channel of about 1 over 2 times
the Doppler spread.
That's important because that
says the channel is going to
look like the same thing for a
period of time, which is about
1 over 2 times this Doppler
spread term.
I think this will be
D instead of D 0.
So you find out what the Doppler
spread is and the
reason you want to find out what
the Doppler spread is is
that that tells you how long
the channel remains stable.
Why do you want to
know how long the
channel remains stable?
If you're going to do detection
or anything like
that, if you're going to filter
the received waveform
to try to find out what the
input waveform is, you would
like to know what the
channel is doing.
You'd like to be able to
measure the channel.
If you're going to measure the
channel, you really want to
know how long it stays the
same before you have to
measure it again.
If you look at all these
cellular systems and you look
at every other wireless system
in the world, all of them do
one of one of two things:
either periodically they
measure what the channel is so
they can use it and the other
thing they do is every once in
awhile, they send a pilot tone
and they use the pilot tone to
try to figure out what kind of
channel they have.
This is the thing which tells
you how often you have to send
that pilots tone.
If you know about estimation
theory, it's also the thing
that tells you whether you
have any chance or not of
estimating what the channel
is, because it takes you a
certain amount of time in the
presence of noise to estimate
something and if that something
you're trying to
estimate it's changing faster
than you can estimate it, then
you don't have a prayer
of a chance.
So yes, this is important.
This is the prime coherence.
It's one of the main parameters
of a wireless
channel you want
to understand.
It tells you how long the
channel will remain
essentially the same before
it changes and
becomes something different.
Both of these quantities
are very approximate.
If anyone wants to tell you that
it's twice what I say it
is here, I certainly wouldn't
quarrel with them.
I mean, it's like talking
about the bandwidth of a
waveform them that you send.
I mean, you look at the spectrum
of what you send and
it's going to be something
which sort of tails off.
If you want to call it the
maximum out there where it's
going to zero or the minimum,
where it starts to go to zero
or what have you, it doesn't
make much difference.
Here, it's a worse situation
because you
don't shape this waveform.
It's just given to you and you
find something which is going
to be tailing off slowly.
It's going to have little bits
of nothingness way out there.
All this is is just one very
approximate number, which
tells you what that Doppler
spread is and therefore, which
tells you how long the channel
is going to remain stable and
yes, in half of that time the
channel starts to change and
in twice that time, the channel
might be still sort of
like it was before.
So this is only a very
approximate way of looking at
these things, but it gives you
an idea about what you can do
and what you can't do.
It gives you an idea, for
example, if you say, can I
take this wireless system I've
been using and use it at a
frequency that's 10
times as high --
and you know when you use it
at a frequency 10 times as
high that the stability of the
channel is going to be 10
times as small.
You know if you were having
trouble measuring the channel
before, you know you don't have
a prayer of a chance when
you go up to that higher
frequency, so it so it tells
you things like that.
There are two other sort of
related quantities, which are
called multipath spread and
coherence frequency.
So we have Doppler spread on
the one hand, which is a
physical phenomena and that
gives rise to coherence time,
which says how long the channel
will stay the same and
in the opposite domain --
and these are almost dual
quantities of each other, you
have something called multipath
spread, which --
and multipath spread is
pretty much what it
sounds like it is.
You have a bunch of
different paths.
You send a very short duration
waveform and things start
trickling in on the shortest
path and then you got a big
bunch of stuff in all the paths
which are sort of the
same lanegth and then they sort
of dribble away again.
So the waveform that you see
coming in is spread out from
what you send because of these
multiple paths and the
multiple paths having different
delays on them.
Because you have all of these
different delay paths, you're
going to have an impulse
response for this channel,
which has a certain
duration to it.
When you take the Fourier
transform of that, you find a
certain duration for
Fourier transform.
As we're going to see in just
a minute, that's the thing
that tells you how stable this
channel is in frequency.
If you measure it at one
frequency, how far do you have
to go in frequency before you
find something which is
totally separate from what
you measure down here?
This is something the
cuts both ways.
Having a large frequency
coherence and having a large
time coherence can be good
or it can be bad.
If you have a very large time
coherence and a very large
frequency coherence, you can
measure the channel once and
you can use it for a long time
and you can use it over a
broadband width and everything
looks very nice.
If the channel happens to be
faded over that long period of
time and over that long interval
of frequency, you're
really in the soup.
On the other hand, if you have
a very small time coherence
and a very small frequency
coherence, if the channel
doesn't look good there, you
move to a different time
interval or you moved to a
different frequency interval
and you can transmit again.
So both of these quantities have
good aspects to them and
bad aspects to them, but if you
want to evaluate what a
physical wireless channel is and
somebody lets you ask two
questions, the two questions you
ought to ask are, what is
the time coherence and what is
the frequency coherence?
Those are the first things
you want to find out.
Everything else is sort
of secondary.
So trying to claim that the
frequency coherence here
almost has a matter
duality, as 1 over
twice the time spread.
Let's take a slide to
see why that is.
If I take the impulse response
at baseband of this channel,
which I wrote down here --
here's the impulse response and
you get that directly from
the baseband response for
giving input waveform.
With all these different paths,
what this impulse
response is at a particular time
t -- namely, this is the
response at time t to an impulse
tau seconds earlier.
In other words, when I'm using
this notation here, I'm really
thinking of t as a receiver
time and t minus tau as
transmit time.
But anyway, this
is what it is.
You take the Fourier transform
of this for a particular t --
in other words, we talked
about this a
little bit last time.
You have a function of two
parameters here and at any
given t at the receiver, what
you see is a spread of
different inputs coming in
from the transmitter.
What we're interested in now is
at that particular time t
at the receiver, what's the
Fourier transform, when you
take the Fourier transform on
tau to see what kinds of
frequencies are coming in?
We take the Fourier transform
of a unit delta function and
you just get an exponential
function.
So the transform of that delta
is just this e to the minus 2
pi if times tau sub
j prime of t.
This is this differential delay
that we're faced with
and we still have the Doppler
shift over here.
So when we look at it this way,
we have both the Doppler
shift sitting there and
we have this delay
shift sitting up here.
Now the question we ask is, how
much does the frequency
have to change before this
quantity is going to change
materially?
The answer is the same
as it was before.
When this quantity here changes
by pi over 2, you have
a totally different result
than you had before.
So the question is, how much
does a frequency have to
change in order for f times tau
j prime of t to the change
by a factor of one-fourth.
So the answer that we come up
with is, this has to go from
minus L over 2 to plus L over 2
and this is where we get the
result that we were just
talking about, that the
frequency coherence is 1 over
2 times the multipath spread
of the channel.
The next thing we want to do
in this long process --
it's a process that we've sort
of been doing all along.
The whole purpose of looking
at waveforms and looking at
digital communication is to be
able to go from sequences to
waveforms --
and what do you think the next
thing we're going to do is?
We're going to go from
these waveforms --
we've now got them down to
baseband waveforms and we want
to go back to looking
at sequences.
So what we would like to do is
to take this input waveform,
view it in terms of the
sampling theorem --
better thing to do would be to
view it in terms of input
pulses, but that's too
complicated for now, so we'll
just take the input waveform and
view it as a sequence of
data that we're sending
-- the u sub k's
times these sinc waveforms.
Same thing we've been
doing all along.
We take a sequence of numbers,
we put little sine x over
x-hats around them and
that gives us a
band limited waveform.
The baseband output is then --
you can look at the same way.
The baseband output
is going to be
limited to the same frequency.
Question here: You have
these Doppler shifts.
So when I send a frequency which
is right up at the limit
of w over 2, what I get back
from that is going to be
spread out a little
bit from that.
So if I send a waveform that's
limited to w over 2, I'm going
to get back a waveform
which is a little
bit bigger than that.
What do I do about that?
I worried about it in the notes
a little bit and I'm
probably going to take it out
from the notes, because as a
practical matter, the amount of
Doppler shift that you get
is such a negligible fraction
of the kind of bandwidth you
would be using for transmission
that you just
want to forget about that.
So we are going to forget about
it and what's coming in
is again a band limited function
with maybe a little
bit of squishiness on it.
We get this baseband output,
which we can then view in
terms of the sampling theorem.
We can sample the output
and what do we get
when we're all done?
Here's the nice thing that we
can jump to: The output at
this free time m is
then the sum --
namely, it's the convolution,
it's the discrete convolution
of what went in at time m, at
time m minus 1, m minus 2, m
plus 1, m plus 2 --
and what we're doing is, we're
designing this recovery time
so the main peak is about a time
0, so k goes from minus
something to plus something here
and then we wind up with
these channel terms, which are
again, sampled at this point
because we can sample them,
because it's only these low
frequency components of the
channel response that make any
difference.
They're the only things that
give us this output here and
this output has already
been filtered
down to this low frequency.
When I look what these
components are, these are big
messes again.
They're sums over all of
these different paths.
So what we're winding up
with is a function --
if I sketch g of tau and t as
a function of tau, what I'm
going to find is a bunch
of different terms.
Now I'm going to filter this
so every one of these turns
into a little sinc x
over x and then I'm
going to sample it.
So what I wind up with then is
this goes into something which
looks like this.
It's going to look like
something which goes up and
comes down again, and I'm just
interested in what it's sample
values are and I might wind up
with five or six sample values
and that expresses
the whole thing.
I mean, this is something you
have to think about a little
bit because it's something that
we've done about 10 times
already, but now when we do it
here it looks very different
from what we've done before --
except this is what it
is analytically.
This is what it is in pictures
and that's where it comes out.
The thing that's going on here
then is we started to look at
this physical modeling in
terms of ray tracing and
things like that and what we're
doing at this point is
we're modeling what's going on
at the frequency bandwidth
that we're using --
namely, not the carrier
frequency anymore, but the
baseband bandwidth.
We're viewing this filter as
having filtered these things
out for us so we wind up with
a baseband discrete filter
that filters these impulses
and aggregates them under
discrete caps.
So at this point, when we look
at this filter for what the
channel is doing, instead of
seeing a bunch of impulses, we
see a rather smooth waveform.
If we look at what contributes
to each tap, we see a large
number of different
paths, which all
contribute to the same tap.
If the multipath spread
is not too large
relative to 1 over w --
if if the multipath spread is
small relative to 1 over w,
then you can really represent
this whole thing in one path.
In other words, if the multipath
spread is very, very
small and the sampling time
interval is big, everything
just appears under one tap and
that's called flat fading.
When you have flat fading, the
output that comes out is
really just a faded version of
the input and there isn't any
time dispersion on it.
It all just --
it's an undistorted version of
what got sent, except it's
very slowly fading and coming
back up again and fading again
and coming back up again.
If you have a slightly wider
bandwidth, then you need
multiple taps.
If you look at most of the of
the systems that are being
built today, the largest number
of taps they ever used
in this kind of implementation
is three to five or something
in that order, so it's not a
huge number of taps that we're
talking about, because the
bandwidths are not huge.
But anyway, statistically what
we wind up with is that if the
bandwidth that we're using is
relatively narrow and it's not
too many times what this
term 1 over L is --
namely, this multipath spread,
then we wind up with a small
number of paths.
We can sort of assume that we
have a large number of paths
coming in on each tap and then
what we're doing is that each
tap strength is going to be a
sum of a bunch of terms which
are essentially random.
If you add up a bunch of
complex terms that are
essentially random,
what do you get?
If you add up a very humongous
number of them, you get
something which is Gaussian.
If you were modeling these
things statistically, you
would like them to
be Gaussian.
So what do you do?
You assume that they're
Gaussian, which is what
everyone does.
As a slight excuse for that,
what we're really interested
in if you're designing cellular
systems, you're
trying to build cellular
receivers which will deal with
all of the different
circumstances that they come
up against and as you walk
around or drive around using
these things, if you look at
the ensemble of different
situations that these phones
are faced with, over that
ensemble of things, each of
these taps is pretty much
going to look like a Gaussian
random variable.
If you look at one sample path
of one little cellular phone,
then no, it won't look like that
-- but as far as a design
tool, it looks like something
which you can model as
Gaussian because you're going to
view each of these taps in
this filter, in this time
varying filter, the sum of
lots of unrelated components and
therefore, we're going to
take the density of these taps
and a statistical model as
being jointly Gaussian --
a proper Gaussian random
variable for each of them.
What happens if different taps
is jointly Gaussian?
So what we wind up with is a
model for wireless channels
then, where the channel itself
is a Gaussian random process
and as a Gaussian random process
both in tau and in t,
it's easier to look at if we
look at it in terms of these
discrete samples.
Namely, we're going to look at
the channel now, not in terms
of a wavelength type of thing.
We're just going to look at it
as a bunch of taps, which the
receiver has to add over to get
to the received waveform.
We're going to model each of
those taps as being Gaussian.
We're going to model in time
t as being stationary.
We're going to model them in
time tau as coming up and
going back down again and
existing over a multipath
spread that's about
L in duration.
So the phase is going to be
uniform with this density.
This is this two dimensional
independent Gaussian density
that we've looked at so many
times and if you look at this,
it has circular symmetry to it,
which means if you look at
it in an amplituding phase, the
phase is random, uniform
between zero and 2 pi.
The energy in it is exponential
and the magnitude
is this, which comes
from that --
which is what you call
a Rayleigh density.
So Rayleigh fading channels are
simply channels which you
have modeled as having
taps, which are
really random variables.
Real and imaginary parts, each
of them have the same
distribution.
I mean, you'd be very very
surprised if you looked at
these taps after the way we've
derived them and you didn't
find the same distribution
on the real part as
the imaginary part.
If you look at the real part
and imaginary part, they're
simply coming as an arbitrary
phase, which comes from some
arbitrary demodulating frequency
that you've used
with a phase in there that
doesn't have any physical
connotation at all.
I mean, what is real is what
you choose to call real and
what is imaginary is what you
choose to call imaginary.
If you made your time reference
just a little bit, a
smidgen away from where your
time reference is, what is
real would become imaginary and
what is imaginary would
become real again and you can't
expect the channel to
know what time reference
you've chosen.
I mean, this is sort of a big
philosophical argument, but
you certainly wouldn't expect
these random variables to have
a distribution which
is anything other
than uniform in phase.
So that's the distribution we
get and what we now have is we
changed this awful physical
situation into a very simple
analytical situation where what
we're doing is modeling
this complex channel as just a
bunch of taps in time, at some
bandwidth that we're using and
each of these taps is now
Gaussian and the output is going
to be the discrete sum
as we take a discrete sequence
of inputs, pass it through
this discrete filter and then we
add up these outputs and at
that point, we have to worry
about how do we detect things
from what's coming out?
So they say here -- this is
a really flaky modeling
assumption and it's only partly
justified by looking at
lots of different situations
that a given cellular phone
would be placed in.
If we look at this whole
ensemble, it makes a little
bit of sense, but really what
we're doing here is saying
what we want is a vehicle to
let us understand how to
receive these waveforms.
We know there is going
to be fading.
Since we know there is going to
be fading, we have to find
some kind of statistical model
for it if we're going to find
sensible things to do
and this is the one
we're going to pick.
It's very common instead of
using a Rayleigh fading model
to use a Rician fading model.
A Rician fading model makes
sense because if you have a
line of sight directly to a base
station, the waveform you
get from the base station is
going to be kind of strong and
all of these waveforms you get
reflected from other obstacles
and so forth are going
to be rather weak.
So in that case, you're going
to have one strong received
waveform, which is one big peak
and everything else is
going to be very weak.
The thing that that says is the
kind of statistics that
you want are not a sum of a lot
of little tiny things, but
the sum of one big thing and
lots of tiny things.
That's not a good
model either.
What you would really like is
a sum of a bunch of medium
sized things most of the time,
but about as far as anybody
gets talking about statistical
models for fading channels is
talking about Rician model and
talking about Rayleigh models
and then worrying about what
happens the different paths of
these filters.
The trouble with Rician random
variables is they're very
complicated.
They have vessel functions
in them.
If you read the notes I passed
out today, you find that when
you try to detect things, when
they've gone through this kind
of Rician fading, everything
is just a bloody mess.
That's the way it is.
Since we are talking now about
a statistical model for these
channels, we would like to have
something called a tap
gain correlation function, which
is going to tell us how
each of these taps
vary in time.
That's just the expected value
of Gkm and G of k prime n.
What we're going to assume, and
what is really a very good
assumption, is if you look at
the things that add up as taps
under a particular value of k
and under some other value of
k -- in other words, all of the
paths that are coming in
in one range of delays and all
the paths that come in on
another range of delays, those
things are pretty much
independent of each other.
So almost always, when you start
calculating tap gain
correlation functions, you
assume that this is
independent when k is
unequal to k prime.
So really the only thing you're
concerned about here is
how these quantities
vary in time.
We've already talked about
how they vary in time.
In other words, that was why
we talked about all of this
business about time coherence
and Doppler shifts.
The thing which is causing these
things to change in time
is these Doppler shifts.
We have already decided that the
amount of time the channel
remain stable is about 1 over
2 times this Doppler spread.
Here we have an analytical,
statistical way of doing the
same thing.
In other words, you can look at
this correlation function
here and you can see how long
it takes before it drops
essentially to zero.
So you can define the time
coherence in terms of this
duration here just as well as
the way we've already done.
In other words, how big does n
have to get before this thing
gets small?
What's the advantage of doing
it this way instead of in
terms of Doppler shifts?
If you want to measure it, you
don't have to go out and
measure where these paths are.
If you want to measure it, you
just take a cellular phone and
you measure where these things
are coming in and how they
change in time and that gives
you a direct view of what the
time coherence is.
Why that W was there, there's
a problem in the problem set
that will give you some insight
into why it's there,
but otherwise it's
just arbitrary.
I want to spend the rest of
the time talking about
Rayleigh fading, because
Rayleigh fading is something
you can analyze easily.
We're going to do something
even simpler.
We're going to do Rayleigh
fading where you have
a single tap model.
In other words, where the
bandwidth that you're using is
small enough that all these
different paths all fall in
the same delay range.
In other words, it's where the
multipath spread, L, is small
relative to 1 over W. That's
what's called flat fading, so
we're assuming flat fading and
we're assuming that it changes
in time according to
a Rayleigh model.
Suppose that we do something
really simple, like trying the
antipodal signalling that we've
been using all along,
which is really neat when
you have Gaussian noise.
It's just about the best kind of
signaling that you can use.
It doesn't work at all here
and it doesn't work at all
because since this channel is
Rayleigh fading, you don't
know what the phase is of the
channel, so you send a bit and
what comes in is something
which, sure, it has an
amplitude to it, but it has a
completely random phase to it,
so you can't tell the
difference between
one and minus one.
The only way you can tell is to
send first one signal and
then another signal, but if
you send one signal and
another signal, you might as
well choose a single pattern
which lets you do
this sensibly.
So the particular thing that
we'll look at is something
called post position
modulation.
This is essentially the same as
about ten other schemes and
we'll talk about that a little
more later, but what you're
going to use is two degrees
of freedom, which is two
different time instants.
In the first instant, you're
going to send an a.
In the second instant, you're
going to send a zero where
conversely, you're going to
send a zero in the first
degree of freedom and an a in
the second degree of freedom.
So you can do this either with
two different frequencies, you
can do it with two different
time instants.
You can do it in all sorts
of different ways.
Any time you have two degrees of
freedom, you either use one
degree of freedom or you use the
other degree of freedom.
It's not like the situation
we've talked about before,
because these degrees of
freedom are now complex
degrees of freedom.
If I send the one, it's going
to come in as some complex
number, which is going to
have uniform phase.
So my hypotheses now are one
hypothesis is a and zero and
the other hypothesis
is zero and a.
What's going to happen with
these hypotheses is that
first, the channel is going
to do its thing to them.
In other words, if I send this,
the channel is going to
take that a.
It's going to multiply it by a
circularly symmetric Gaussian
random variable, so it's going
to come as some blob and in
the other dimension, what I send
is a zero, so what comes
in there is nothing.
I'm going to add noise to this,
so when I send a zero,
I'm going to get --
from the channel, I
get a blob in this
first degree of freedom.
The noise adds another
blob, which is
also circularly symmetric.
What comes in the other degree
of freedom is zero on the
channel and a blob of noise.
So I'm going to base my
detection on either a big blob
or a little blob and on the
other hypothesis, I got a
little blob here and
a big blob there.
So the question is, you have to
look at this pair of blobs
and decide from it what
you think was
the most likely signals.
Sounds hard, but it turns out
that it's easy, because look,
under the hypothesis H 0, what
you're going to receive --
and these are a times a complex
variable, G 0 plus Z 0.
Both of these are Gaussian
random variables, both zero
mean, both circularly symmetric
and V 1 is going to
be just Z 1.
So here I have a sum of two
Gaussian random variables.
Here I have one Gaussian
random variable.
V 0 is complex Gaussian and its
variance is a squared plus
N 0 times W, because that's
what the noise is.
So I look at the probability
density of these two complex
Gaussian random variables,
sample value v 0 and v 1,
conditional on H 0.
What I have is some
constant here --
I don't even care about it --
times e need to the minus
v 0 squared divided by a
squared plus wn 0.
This is the variance of
V 0, because V 0 was a
squared times G 0.
That's the a squared there.
Variance is Z 0 WN 0 and for the
other random variable --
that's the little blob
random variable --
probability density of that
is minus v 1 squared
divided by WN 0.
For the alternative hypothesis,
I get the same
constant out front, which I
haven't even bother to write
down, times e to the minus
v 0 squared over WN 0.
Here are the other variables:
The one where we have the big
blob, so that's the variance
a squared plus WN 0.
I take the log likelihood ratio,
which is to take the
logarithm of the ratio of these
two hypotheses, of these
two likelihoods, and when I take
this quantity and divide
it by this quantity, these are
both up in the exponents, so
I'm just taking this and
subtracting this.
When I subtract this quantity
from this quantity and then
subtract this quantity from this
quantity, what I get is
just this quantity here.
I mean, you can see it's simple
because this difference
is going to be the same as this
difference, except they
have a different sign.
So it's just algebra to find out
what happens when you when
you take this minus this
and then you take
minus this plus this.
This is what you get.
Then you look at that for a bit
and you say, how do I find
the probability of
error from this?
Before we find the probability
of error, the first thing we
have to do is say, what's
the maximum
likelihood rule to use here?
Maximum likelihood rule is you
take the log likelihood ratio
and if it's positive,
you choose v0.
If it's negative, you choose v1
and if it's 0 -- if 0 was
zero probability, it doesn't
matter what you do.
So what we're interested
in now is, what is the
probability that this quantity
here is going to
be bigger than zero?
But you see, this isn't hard
because when you look at the
difference between v 0 squared
and v 1 squared, v 0 squared
is an exponential
random variable.
It's just the energy of
a complex Gaussian.
So we're taking one exponential
random variable,
subtracting off another
exponential random variable
and we're just looking at it
over on the region where these
things are positive.
When you integrate that, this
is the answer that you get.
I mean, it's not hard
to integrate it.
I just don't --
and if you look at the notes,
the notes carry it out in all
of its gory detail, but it
really is about two steps.
The thing we want to look at is
this result here, because
it looks so different from all
of the error probability
results that we've
gotten before.
I mean, before, error
probabilities go down
exponentially as a square of
the signal amplitudes that
we're using and they go down
exponentially with the energy
that we're using.
Here, this crazy thing is going
down as 1 over 2 plus
energy to noise ratio.
This is 1 over 2 plus
Ed over N 0.
So it really goes down slowly.
So what's going on?
I mean, why is it that with all
of these Gaussian random
variables where things go down
so fast, we're really in such
deep trouble here?
The trouble is, every time the
fading is significant and the
fading is significant
whenever --
under hypothesis 0, if
you don't have much
of a channel --
namely, if both v 0 and
v 1 are both very --
if both the real part of G 0 and
the imaginary part of G 0
are both very small --
which happens with reasonable
probability --
then you don't have a chance of
trying to decode correctly
because the two signals are both
going to look the same,
because both of them are just
Gaussian random variables.
So as a result of that, when
you're dealing with Rayleigh
fading, you really have to find
something else to do in
order to make this work.
I mean, if you have Rayleigh
fading and you just try to
communicate in the way that we
tried to communicate before --
just sending individual bits
and hoping for the best,
you're in very deep trouble.
So next time we'll start to
talk about ways of dealing
with this using diversity, using
channel measurement,
using all sorts of other
things, but --
I don't know what happened to
the person who was supposed to
evaluate the class, but maybe
they will come in next week.
I don't Know.